فوائد الرضاعه الطبيعيه وعن تاثيرها على
مرحله الطفوله لكن ان يمتد مفعولها لسن
البلوغ
والمراهقه ايضا هو امر مختلف وغير متوقعه
بريطانيه توصلت الى نتيجه مذهله مده
الرضاعه قد تؤثر على نتائج المراهقين في
اختباراتهم الدراسيه لاحقا الدراسه قامت
بتعاقب حوالي 5000 طفل منذ ولادتهم في
اوائل العقد الاول من القرن ال 21 الى
عامهم الاخير في المدرسه الثانويه النتيجه
كانت الاطفال الذين تغذوا من الرضاعه
الطبيعيه لمده 12 شهرا في الحد الادنى
كانوا اكثر ميلا بنسبه 39% لاجتياز
اختبارات الرياضيات كما كان احتمال رسبهم
في امتحان اللغه الانجليزيه
ادنى بنسبه 25% هلا معروف انه رضا يعني
فوائدها كثيره ولكن هل يمكن انه تكون هاي
الدراسه صدفه معقول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات